whoo way means in Chinese nan doing or
doing nothing it sounds like a pleasant
invitation to relax or worse fall into
laziness or apathy yet this concept is
key to the noblest kind of action
according to the philosophy of Taoism
and is at the heart of what it means to
follow Dao or the way according to the
central text of Taoism the daodejing the
way never acts yet nothing is left
undone this is the paradox of Wu Wei it
doesn't mean not acting
it means effortless action or action
'less action it means being at peace
while engaged in the most frenetic tasks
so that one can carry these out with
maximum skill and efficiency something
of the meaning of Wu Wei is captured
when we talk of being in the zone at one
with what we're doing in a state of
profound concentration and flow Wu Wei
is closely connected to the Taoist
reverence for the natural world for it
means striving to make our behavior as
spontaneous and inevitable as certain
natural processes and to ensure that we
are swimming with rather than against
currents we are to be like the bamboo
that bends in the wind or the plant that
adjusts itself to the shape of a tree we
way involves letting go of ideals that
we may otherwise try to force to
violently onto things it invites us
instead to respond to the true demands
of situations which tend only to be
noticed when we put our own ego driven
plans to one side what can follow is a
loss of self-consciousness a new unity
between the self and its environment but
none of this means we won't be able to
change or affect things if we strive for
Wu Wei the daodejing points out that we
should be like water which is submissive
and weak and yet which can't be
surpassed for attacking what is hard and
strong through gentle persistence and a
compliance with a specific shape of a
problem an obstacle can be worked around
and gradually eroded the idea of
achieving the greatest effects by a wise
strategic passivity has been central to
Chinese notions of politics deploy
you see in business in the manuals on
wisdom produced by Daoists we are
repeatedly told that rather than impose
a plan or model on a situation we should
let others act frantically and then
likely adjust ourselves as we see the
direction that matters have evolved in
in china's tang dynasty many poets
likened wu way to the best aspects of
being drunk
it wasn't alcoholism they were promoting
but the decline in rigidity and anxiety
that sometimes comes with being a little
drunk and which can help us to
accomplish certain tasks one poet
compared someone inspired by wu way to a
drunk man who falls uninjured from a
moving cart such as their spiritual
momentum that they are unaffected by
accidents and misfortunes that might
break those of a more controlled and
controlling mindset theories of painting
from the tang period onwards made wu way
central to artistic practice rather than
laborious li attempting to reproduce
nature as faithful copyists the artist
should find nature within themselves and
surrender to its calls the painter's
task is not to imitate the external
surface of things but to present the cui
or spirit of things like mountains trees
birds and rivers by feeling some of this
spirit in themselves and then letting it
flow out through the brush onto silk or
paper it followed that Taoist thinkers
revered not just the finished work of
art but the act of painting itself and
considered artist studios as places for
applied philosophy the Tang Dynasty poet
whose eye described a big party that had
been thrown to witness the painter Zhang
Joe in action right in the middle of the
room he sat down with his legs spread
out took a deep breath and his
inspiration began to issue forth those
present were as startled as if lightning
was shooting across the heavens or a
whirlwind was sweeping up into the sky
the ink seemed to be spitting from his
flying brush he clapped his hands with a
cracking sound suddenly strange shapes
were born when he'd finished there stood
pine trees scaly and Riven crags steep
and precipitous clear water and
turbulent clouds he threw down his brush
got up and looked around in every
direction it seemed as if the
I had cleared after a storm to reveal
the true essence of 10,000 things whose
I added of Zang whose works are sadly
now lost that he had left mere skill
behind and that his art was not painting
but the very Dow itself a good life
could not be attained by Wu Wei alone
but this Taoist concept captures a
wisdom we may at times be in desperate
need of when we're in danger of damaging
ourselves through an overly Stern and
unyielding adherence to ideas which
simply don't fit the demands of the
world
you